alors vous aussi vous avez beaucoup à
lutter dans votre vie on va en parler
marie-claude je t'aime déjà parce
qu'après j'ai peur que tu me crois plus
vous étés à paris en 1963 mère
bordelaise père corse
m
signalez bien sebastian zbik bon
la classe
on a une série black
les eaux
oh oh oh
ça nous fait rien alors dérange à lens
le nord est ce que tu peux oublier nous
chanter pour le plus attention à toi moi
si j'étais peut-être un petit peu
dérangé a dit le président yayi n'était
pas grave est qu aller on est juste de
commencer coude n'auront pas attention
publique va mal pour le plaisir
rires pendant le temps de temps en temps
de refaire d'un homme un enfant et
s'éblouit ont le plaisir
merci
grâce à la bouche général à tous
le cas
avec à séoul
non